foreign
[Music]
a little bit about me I code in R for a
living and I believe R can be fun
what do I mean by fun I mean things like
including kittens in GG plots
running destructive physics simulations
and currently I'm experimenting with
voxel rendering
there is fun to be had in our and today
I'd like to share with you such a
discovery
and that is with careful use of Base
hour interactive Graphics are possible
and this opens the way for new
visualizations
and when I say news visualizations I'm
going to use it to play games
my need for interactive Graphics started
with the game Wordle
this has an intuitive interface with
animations and a great user experience
and so I created a clone of this in art
to play
this was a text-based interface which
feels a bit clunky it does not have the
feel or the fluidity of the official
game
and I realized
R gives easy access to text interfaces
like Zork on the left
but I want to play actual video games
with sound and color and graphics and
actual interaction like Pac-Man on the
right
so I set myself a moonshot goal I knew
where I wanted to go but I didn't know
how I was going to get there
and my moonshot was this
I will commit myself to achieving the
goal before this year is out of writing
and playing a video game in r
but this then raises the question what
extra things do I need to know in r in
order to get a game running
and I needed to be sure of three things
and I'm going to discuss this with you
today and that is a fast Graphics device
for rendering too
a fast way of drawing to this Graphics
device to render the game
and mouse and keyboard interaction so we
can actually play the game
a fast Graphics device is essential if I
actually want to play games
I need the graphics to respond at least
30 frames per second if not then the
games will never run smoothly
when I say Graphics device I'm referring
to the area or window where the plots
are displayed in r like the plot window
in our studio
on the Mac there are a few other
Graphics devices there's the quartz and
the X11 device
and I needed to compare them to find out
what their speed and response times were
I wrote a very simple Benchmark to test
how fast a graphics device would respond
to a simple plotting command
and I was pleasantly surprised
that the graphics devices can respond at
30 times per second
in this plot we see the r studio and the
quartz device both reaching 30 frames
per second with the quartz device about
twice as fast as the rstudio device
what was really surprising was to see
that the X11 device can respond to
commands at over 500 times per second
so yes R does have a fast Graphics
device we're over the first hurdle all
Graphics devices can respond fast enough
and some graphics devices are faster
than others on the Mac I'm going to
choose to use the X11 device because it
is ridiculously fast
now that I'm confident that the graphics
device can respond quickly I need a fast
way of drawing to that Graphics device
my focus is on Pixel based games so
blocky pixels and polygons and character
sprites moving around like the game of
Pac-man
a character sprite like this cartoon
dinosaur is just a collection of colored
squares and this can be drawn very
quickly using just a base R Graphics
command grid Direct
if I draw this clear the screen and draw
it again over and over I can get some
animation
to ensure this drawing system can scale
I'm going to use a common animation
technique known as double buffering
in double buffering there is one buffer
for drawing and one buffer for rendering
to the screen
and I'm going to implement it in R like
this
I'm going to create a buffer in R and
then for every frame draw the game into
the buffer and when that buffer is ready
copy that buffer into the graphics
device
for the drawing buffer I first
considered a standard R Matrix
it seems like a pretty good match for
representing rectangular array of pixels
on the screen
but I ran into some challenges that
actually slowed things down
and that is the data ordering and the
color representation within a matrix
in a matrix the data ordering is such
that sequential values Define a column
in a graphics device it wants to
sequential values to define a row of
pixels
so there is a mismatch between their
data representation
there is also mismatching the color
representation in an R Matrix it would
represent color as a string
but a graphics device actually wants
four numeric values for the four bytes
of red green blue and Alpha color
channels
so the Matrix data layer does not match
the graphics device which means if I was
to render a matrix to the graphics
device then every single time it
actually has to do an internal data
conversion and this is going to slow
things down
there is actually a second rectangular
data structure in r that is more
compatible with Graphics devices
and that is the native raster
the native raster is a built-in data
structure in R but it is rarely used
it's difficult to manipulate from R but
it is highly compatible with Graphics
devices
uh this table illustrates that the
native raster object and the graphics
device have the same data ordering and
the same color representation
this means that the native raster
objects will be very fast to copy to the
graphics device as no conversion will
need to be done
so my specific double buffered rendering
technique looks like this
I will create a native raster buffer in
R then for every frame draw the game
into that buffer and then when it's
ready copy that buffer to the graphics
device but just with the grid raster
command
this is a really powerful and scalable
technique it allows R to render multiple
Sprites very quickly
as a demonstration that this double
buffering technique works this is a live
capture of three animated dinosaurs
this is great but three objects aren't
going to make an interesting game
and as I said this method scales and it
scales too
100 dinosaurs
one thousand dinosaurs
and the limit I could reach before the
drawing speed dropped below the magic 30
frames per second
was five thousand dinosaurs
and I was really happy with this
R has a fast way of drawing if I use the
double buffering technique using a
native raster as the drawing buffer and
then copy that buffer to the graphics
device when it's ready
the final piece of the puzzle is
interactivity an essential element of
any game that you actually want to play
a standard way you currently might get
feedback from the user is to request
text using the read line command as
shown here
when calling readline ah cannot do
anything else it must have the user
input before it proceeds to the next
line
in a similar manner you can get the
mouse position using grid locator
but again while waiting for the user
input R cannot do anything else
so using this style of interaction would
not work for video games imagine a game
of Pac-man where the game stopped every
time you needed to control the main
character it's not going to be an
interesting game or very fun
we have to change our programming
approach and make use of the event
driven capabilities of our Graphics
devices
in event-driven interaction we ask the
system to monitor for events and when
they occur we ask them to run a
particular function
for those of you familiar with shiny it
is based on an event-driven framework
if you had a button on your web page you
would not write a for Loop to check
whether the button has been clicked
you would ask the system in this case
shiny that when the button is clicked
please run my function and that's what
the observe event handler is in shining
like shiny are Graphics devices support
event-driven interaction
so we don't need to monitor has the
mouse moved or has the keyboard been
pressed we can ask the graphics device
to monitor for us and when that event
occurs run a particular function
this is all handled by the gr device
package in the set Graphics event
handlers function where you can tie
functions to particular events
the events that you can watch for
has the mouse moved and you'll get back
the coordinates of the mouse you can
monitor for the mouse button being
pressed in which case you will get back
the button number
you can ask for the keyboard to be
monitored in which case you will get
which key has been pressed
there is one extra event to be monitored
and that is the idle event where no
other events are happening
consider the idle event to be like the
heartbeat of an application
when the user is doing something yes we
handle that input and change our values
but if the user is not doing anything
then we run our idle function our
heartbeat
this means that an application skeleton
might look something like this
when the mouse moves let's update the
position of the character on the screen
when the keyboard is pressed let's run a
function that will check whether the
user wants to quit
and when the user is otherwise idle
render the next frame in the animation
as proof that this event-driven
interactivity works I wrote a drum
machine in r
a drum machine is just an electronic
instrument that plays drums
in this drum machine interface each row
represents an instrument and each button
means to play that instrument at a
certain moment in time
the events that I've tied to this
application are that when the mouse
button is pressed we toggle the button
underneath the mouse
and when the user is Idle we just
continue to play the next beat in the
sequence
this is a short 20 second clip showing
the first song I ever composed in r
this was a lot of fun to program and
great fun to experiment with and compose
my own songs
and it shows that event-driven
interaction does work for what I want
for games I can simultaneously render
graphics and play sounds while reacting
to user input
I now have all the key elements that I
need to play a game
the only thing left is to actually write
the game itself
and I'm not going to write a game from
scratch I'm actually going to Port an
existing game called Another World
another world is an action adventure
side scrolling platformer released in
1991 for many platforms it has a novel
for its time virtual machine
architecture which makes it easy to port
to new systems
it is in effect just a polygon engine
rather than storing bitmaps for scenes
it just records a description of how to
render that scene using polygons
in this 20 second clip it render it is
rendering the first scene in the game
and the next scene is rendering a
lighter scene in the game where the main
character is having a drink
so that's how an individual frame is
rendered for the actual gameplay of
another world I created an R
implementation of the virtual machine
this was based upon the JavaScript and
the C versions which were originally
based upon the assembly versions for
MS-DOS in the amiga
the event-driven game Loop is quite
simple and I asked the graphics device
when the mouse or keyboard are used it
calls the function to update the
variables in my virtual machine and when
the user is otherwise idle it just
executes the next instruction maybe to
draw a polygon or play us out
which means I can show you the demo of
the game
this is a capture running live in r
and to preview what's coming what you're
going to see it is the typical life of a
scientist you arrive at work in your
Ferrari you drink at your desk and then
your experiment gets hit by lightning
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
with that strike of lightning you are
transported to another world
later in the game you are captured and
you're stuck inside a jail
this 10 second demo illustrates keyboard
interaction
by using the left and right arrow keys I
am going to rock the jail and Escape
foreign
s quite abruptly because I have not yet
completed my goal there are still bugs
to fix and a package to release before I
can claim that I have a playable game in
our
what's next
hopefully today with this presentation
I've managed to demonstrate that yes
with careful use of basar interactive
Graphics are possible and this opens the
way to play games
any visualizations
I have released packages to document
this work and I encourage you to try
them
if you want to manipulate native rest
images from R I've released the banara
package
I've released a friendlier wrapper
around the event callbacks in the
graphics devices
this hopefully makes it a little bit
easier to use for games
I know that Matt Dray has used it
already for his retrogrunden crawler
where we can see his blue character
being chased by the yellow monster
if you want to see an example of a
complex event-driven application I have
released the drum machine as a package
and I hope soon to release the another
world package so that everyone can play
this game
R has the capability to write and run
interactive graphics and games and I'm
fascinated to see what the r Community
can create
game on
thank you
[Music]